la presidenta Dina boluarte afirmó que
el adelanto de elecciones en Perú está
cerrado y que ella y los integrantes de
su gobierno continuarán trabajando en
forma responsable en respeto al Estado
de derecho la democracia y la
Constitución hasta Julio de 2026 la
mandataria peruana realiza esta
pronunciamiento en momentos en que tiene
un 77% de desaprobación a sujeción según
últimas encuestas sus opositores le
recuerdan que la negativa de al adelanto
de elecciones por parte del parlamento y
su gobierno fue la exigencia al
estallido social en el sur del Perú que
se extendió a diferentes regiones del
país precisamente diversos colectivos
sociales están convocando a nueva
jornadas de protesta para el 19 de julio
en rechazo a Dina boluarte por las
muertes ocurridas en las marchas que se
desarrollaron entre diciembre de 2022 y
enero de 2023 algunos analistas
advierten que boluarte no conecta con la
población que está generando mayor
rechazo por otro lado señalan que la
jefa de estado se encuentra a punto de
perder el apoyo de la derecha en el
congreso quienes podría n censurar a sus
ministros y quizás luego emprender un
proceso o vacancia presidencial contra
la gobernante en las últimas horas la
lideresa opositora keiko fujimori
criticó la situación de Dina boluarte y
anunció un cambio de actitud de su
bancada en el congreso